look if you're finding yourself having
way too many arguments and debates and
even heated debates with friends and
family on social media at the house
during the pandemic shut down whatever
maybe that's leading to arguments and
not talking to one another this videos
for you look when it comes down to the
way you got a lot of different topics to
debate and some of them get more heated
than others for example I asked the
question the other day on Twitter saying
what debate topic leads to the most
arguments here's what was said this is
some of the ones that were came up
vaccine anti vs. Pro coronavirus you
know capitalism versus socialism minimum
wage school and religion pro-life versus
pro-choice messy versus Ronaldo who's
the greatest soccer player of all time
Jordan versus LeBron basketball player
censorship dogs vs. cats feminism racism
aliens AI guns climate change gets
heated taxes should we have flat tax or
progressive tax immigration the wall
government spending healthcare Coke
versus Pepsi prostitution church versus
state LGBTQ community 5g shut down let's
open up the economy stimulus checks
we're bailing out too many companies we
should be bailing them out drugs
marijuana Foreign Affairs tariffs there
are so many topics to debate that too
often people are worried about debating
or people don't debate often so recently
I had a conversation with Bobby Kennedy
we did a three our exclusive interview
together and I talked about a lot of
different things we talked a lot about
vaccines anti Pro we talked a lot about
coronavirus we talked a lot about a lot
of things but one of the things came up
I said look your position to take would
vaccine has upset some of your family
members three of your relatives wrote an
open letter and they called you out they
said RFK we love you but you are wrong
how do you feel about the fact that your
own family wrote a public letter open
letter to you how do you feel about that
here's his answer powerful answer
Kennedys have 105 different kids in the
family so it's a very big family
that's not a big deal and my family
here's how was raised I was raised in a
family of 12 I've come home every night
and my parents would force us to debate
different topics my dad would say do you
think LSD is good good for you what do
you think about fascism in Italy what do
you think about the economy what do you
think about this what do you think about
that he said we were constantly forced
to debate each other so much that that
was part of the family so to me it's
okay that one of my family members is
coming after me publicly we're used to
that can you imagine that mindset of
that family constantly challenging the
kids to be debating different topics so
if you're somebody that sitting there
saying oh my gosh I don't like to do
that because I don't want to ruffle
people's feathers or if you're somebody
that you're like you can't even help
yourself you always want to get good
matter to get into an argument I want to
give you the next part because there are
some things you ought to be thinking
about when you are debating here's the
reality of it opposing ideas create
conflict opposing ideas anti Pro
anti-vaccine Pro Maxine they debate they
have different ideas they debate or
abuse or another
Reesa Reesa Reesa they debate and then
BOOM we have some truth that comes out
right so remember opposing ideas create
conflicts conflict leads to debate
debate leads to clarity best possible
solution new ideas the key word debate
disclaimers proper debate what do I mean
about proper debate so again opposing
ideas creates conflict conflicts leads
to debate debate leads to clarity best
possible solution new ideas they go at
it here's what we came up with minimum
wage we don't need a minimum wage they
go out and they come up with an idea
taxes let's raise taxes let's reload
taxes boom they go out of immigration go
at it until something comes on I keep
this term on there are some ideas that's
my personal preference like for instance
Coke versus you know Pepsi who cares
it's a taste that's about your taste
dogs vs. cats there is nobody that's
right in dogs vs. cats or LeBron vs.
Jordan yes you can go to the data and
show the fact that Jordan wants six
championships and never went to Game
seven and was MVP six out of six and you
averaging 32 points a game as I get a
LeBron career stats 30,000 points 8,000
8,000 the guys went to a chat yeah I
totally get it I get it but it's still
situational you can still make an
argument for wilt versus Kobe versus
Jordan versus LeBron the other ideas the
more there is debate can lead to a great
idea can lead to something Roddy says I
cannot believe it that's amazing what if
we did I like it let's do that that's
fair because this side gets covered with
this and I don't know about this
research I looked at the research done
by this scientists great data you know
what that doesn't mean if that's the
case I'm good to go right I'm good to go
to do this part so now we've covered all
this stuff here my lifetime I've debated
a lot of people I've argued a lot of
people I eventually came to conclusion
of who I no longer put my energy into I
got a call from a friend of mine the
other day he and his wife he and I had a
conversation together for an hour and a
half a a very very successful athlete
and he brought up some topics that
they're debating going back and four and
I said look I made I made a decision a
long time ago who I do debate who I
don't debate he said who are they
here's who I do debate and I'm willing
to have a real discourse we've gone back
and forth to have a real conversation
together and who I will not entertain
here's who it is number one if somebody
had a life-changing event that'll let
them to the opinion of what they had the
position that they have I'm not debating
it for example if we're talking about
guns right
I'm military I have guns I believe you
ought to have guns to protect yourself
but that's my position my background I
was born and raised in Iran so you
couldn't have anything so the government
control so my life experiences
requirement to protect my family
but if I talk to somebody and in their
house they left the gun alone in the pin
in the drawer one of their kids gets it
and it killed somebody I'm not debating
that person that cost your kid's life
I'm not debating it I just let that part
be done by itself and let them go out
there and experience it and let them do
their own research and maybe one moment
by themselves they're gonna make that
decision
it is not on me to sit and debate
a life-changing event that caused them
to go there that's a different story
number two if somebody who is stubborn
or their know-it-all or they don't do
research and they're lazy what is the
purpose of having the debate meaning if
somebody just wants to argue to want to
argue and get onto your skin if you
catch yourself debating with them you
are them if you wrestle with a pig
you're a pig if you debate a fool you
are the real fool so don't let a fool
get you to go to his level you've heard
this before I'm not the first person
that's telling you this you've seen
these memes or quotes that people post
those communities I don't put a lot of
energy into who do I put an energy into
somebody that believes in an idea
because of traditions meaning you're a
Republican because your entire family
has been in a military so your
pro-republican great let's debate it
okay you're a Democrat because you're a
middle-eastern
or you're Latino or you're African
American your entire life you've been
voting this way because that's what
you're supposed to do let's debate it
like if it's tradition family you know
it's just how we've done things our
entire lives and they've never been
challenged and pushed and they're
willing to have that argument and
they're willing to have that debate
together let's talk about it let's have
a discourse together and then the other
part is education University professor
and mentor so even if they're here and
they're stubborn I have no time but if
they're here and they're willing to have
an educated debate it's beautiful when
that takes place when couple ideas go
together and you're sitting there one
time I was at a restaurant in Glendale
and my friends and I it was like eight
of us everybody is important to me at
that table we're sitting there and all
of a sudden the debate came up one of
the guys in this place used to be a very
strong Christian he had a falling-out
with a pastor so he is now completely
against Christianity and he's all about
you know atheist or agnostic or you know
I don't know if God exists very strong
opinions of math guys with a lot of
logic and used to sell God in a very
logical and emotional way he's had a big
following up then there's another guy
here who's somebody that's gone through
it as well probably 10 years older than
him a lot of experiences ran a big
business did well for himself in New
York was making 16 million a year good
connect education and then there's a guy
over here who's very well-read in the
Bible and they went at it I sat there
for an hour and a half said nothing and
just listened to them go these were all
reasonable men they were all well-read
men they were all questioning the right
topics they were all being respectful
that hour and a half if it was recorded
it would have 10 million views it was so
beautiful to see something like that
take place when you experience a
beautiful debate amongst people that are
willing to allow the ideas to clash
would I go on personal and name-calling
you become wiser afterwards because you
have all the books all the life
experiences of three four or five people
that are going at it that that is that
is a hundred plus years two hundred plus
years of effort put into an idea that
you get to just witness right there like
wow that was a beautiful thing
not as hoping about name-calling all
this sub politics and the last couple of
big kids has gotten a little bit uglier
than it ever was before because people
are not going after you know personal
and all this other stuff and social
media and all these things sometimes you
don't get a real debate I think if they
created some criterias that if you're
going back and forward debating and
you're purely debating a topic and
there's a point system that if you go
personal to me or to the person you're
getting away from the idea you lose
debate points kind of like when you're
boxing and you go low you lose a point
if you go below the best the same thing
here if if in a UFC John Jones had a
loss his first fight he got a loss
because he was elbowing the person on
the ground and at the before the
committee he was a part of he could do
that but you couldn't do it in UFC he
crushed the guy but he got a loss
because it's points taken you can't do
that if we allowed debates to be more
around the topic for debating rather
than go impersonal I think it would be
more fascinating and by the way for some
of you guys that are watching this I did
an interview with Dennis Prager this
last week on live I'll give you the link
to watch in exactly what minute to go
because it is an hour you don't need to
watch the whole thing if you choose it's
an entertaining one but I'll say exactly
where to go there was a part where
Dennis Prager and I Dennis
Praeger has been listened to for three
four decades by tens of millions of
people tens of millions of people many
years ago 10 15 years ago he and I used
to go to a friend's house in Malibu
who's a billionaire owner of public
storage it's worked on four or five
billion dollars and this community would
come together and there would be
beautiful debates and it's only like 40
50 of us at the house great experience
that took a lot of friends to this place
to see it so Dennis was on and I said
Dennis in a perfect world would do you
think America is very divided right and
said do you think it's good that America
is divided right he says no I said do
you think in a perfect world it'd be
better if everybody got along he says
yes he says I believe if everybody
agreed with my ideas this would be a
better place I said if everybody agreed
with your ideas you wouldn't have a job
because your entire job is about
debating and then he says that's fine I
don't care about not having a job I want
to make sure our ideas are together I
don't think there's anything wrong with
debate I don't think there's anything
wrong with proper debate as long as it
doesn't get personal because this is the
idea getting a black eye if the idea
gets a black eye it's okay if you want
to go after human beings everybody's
flawed everybody's got issues the only
difference between somebody that's more
flawed and another person is that person
whose information is more public the
other person is not there's not a single
person that doesn't have some internal
flaws or issues or challenges or vices
that others don't know about some are
more public but an idea let him get a
black eye as much as possible let me get
a black as much as possible that's what
beautiful discourse if done properly on
any of these topics it's wisdom
sometimes people watch my debates and
they say I don't like the way you push
the guy that you were interviewing I
just feel like you're this and you're
that I said I agreed with the guy I was
interviewing but I interview to
challenge an idea to see if I can get
more clarity and the audience can get
more clarity to say uh-huh I didn't
think about that before sometimes I sit
with a guest and I disagree with them
but I'm pushing them on an idea because
I want to get my own clarity as well so
having said I got two videos I want you
to watch one of them is a format of
debate we did at that time everybody
tockman marijuana so I brought two folks
to come down commander of the US Navy
from Southern California we brought him
down and we brought somebody else from
normal the developmental director of
normal and we had them debate marijuana
and this led to alcohol drugs a bunch of
different things and it ended up being a
great format because at the bottom every
time somebody got something wrong we
would put red and every time somebody
got something right we would put green
so if you've not seen this before it's
very entertaining click that to watch
this and if you want to see my interview
with Dennis Prager I the last we go to
the 53 minute mark if you go to 53
minute mark you'll see my discourse with
them back and forth it's always
entertaining when Dennis and I talk
first time here not had a conversation
together that led to a debate but this
one was beautiful because he's willing
to push and challenge and be challenged
which always leads to good conversation
if you've not subscribed to the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody
take care
[Music]